hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play neverending
nightmares now this is a really cool
game that I saw at PAX is currently on
Kickstarter right now but it's just kind
of talking with the developer was
amazing because this guy he admitted
that he had a lot of mental illnesses
that he suffered like through depression
and social disorders or something along
those lines and he channeled it he
channeled all those problems that he had
into this game to try to fuel the
nightmares of this game so um it was
really cool from what I saw if you
remember my playthrough Fran bow this
will kind of be like that because it's
down to the point-and-click adventure
style but anyway this is just an early
demo but it's meant to showcase what
it's all about
neverending nightmares is still in early
development this demos rough around the
edges but we feel that it gives you an
idea of what we want to create which is
what I just said nevermind we can't make
the game without you we need you to back
the project so we can afford to finish
it we also need your feedback tell us
what you like and what you think needs
work we look forward to hearing from you
and hope you enjoy neverending
nightmares okay so I'll be on the
keyboard here alt f4 - quit yeah cuz I'm
gonna be ragequitting with the horrific
monsters try to eat my face hello
sorry what oh sorry
okay I guess that was one of those
neverending nightmares okay so I'm
currently in the game so I'm walking
around and is that Slenderman look at
the painting over there it's a little
girl Slenderman
how's it going over there okay so space
to interact I believe I can't seem to
open that drawer look at the painting
let me see if I can get closer the audio
is very good it's very subtle but I can
hear those that what is with that
okay the shadows seem to be represented
by this overcast of pencil sketches I'm
gonna turn up the volume on this one
because there's a look
what is that is that a demented goat man
okay all right so let me just go out
this door yeah perfectly normal in my
own oh goodness
great this blood on this sink I always
love when that happens this is actually
really cool because I mean it seems
subtle and but I mean look because
they're actually like moving shadows
along the ground but I mean the art
style seems simplistic but at the same
time it's really really well done I like
it a lot okay let's go there's another
picture there's the same picture with
the little girl in Slendy man behind her
care those shadows moving on the ground
there that is actually really cool not
just my shadows but I mean the actual
overcast blackness that's just kind of
all over the place that's really cool
this is an intensely creepy atmosphere
there's that goat man again
mm man
oh man wait a minute isn't this oh this
is just a different bedroom okay
why is this guy living in this house it
seems like a poor idea let's go to bed
in this bed no okay
oh man that's intensely those little
lines the little black lines they're
moving I didn't even notice that before
oh it seems like the shadows are getting
more pervasive as I go along that's what
I'm gonna call that black like overcast
the shadows which it I guess is with it
oh yeah I'm gonna go down there that's a
great idea why not all right
terrific no how about well that's not
any better okay why whoa
what is that I hear something alright
let's go into the dark oh okay it was
just a transition good
seriously this is creepy as hell what's
going on here Oh little toy soldiers how
I love to play with that does that say
Mudder
mmm ude our mom well that's not so bad
this means mutter oh okay
why is this got to be so ding dong damn
creepy
you are some kind of horrific that I
want nothing to do with okay okay all
right let's go in this room please why
is that one doll with its head covered
well that's one good that's my demonic
horse impression
what's with the dolls what's with the
dolls
what's with the dolls what's with the
doll oh man see this game is hitting on
all the subjects that I always say in a
horror game and that just means
atmosphere above all else atmosphere and
this is like the style of the game in
its pencil sketch black-and-white is so
perfect for what it's representing it's
amazingly well that I didn't even know
if the faces on that painting of the
corn stock there don't mind me
demonic monsters
you
that's tricky why normally there's just
a little cute little cuckoo bird oh good
this area the house is dark look at that
look how cool that is I don't know how
they do that but it's like there's some
actual dynamic shading going along in
this 2d world it's really intricate
really well done it showcases a much
deeper watt all right terrific good for
you it showcases a much deeper world
than was represented by the simplistic
style I've tried to say these profound
things but in reality we just don't want
to die I really don't want to die I
don't know how they big this house is
but I keep seem to be going in circles
over and over that a letter can I read
that her I hear you
I don't think I've missed any rooms in
LA
Oh mannequins you like those mannequins
from nightmare house two guys by the way
if you haven't seen my playthrough a
nightmare house - I highly recommend it
oh there are skulls on the wallpaper I
didn't even notice that there's so many
subtle things that had men noticing okay
oh man I mean it's like things are so
uniform in the awaken oh never mind I'm
gonna stop trying to say profound things
and I'm just gonna go through the game
okay this is the door at the end of the
hall
I haven't gone in the basement yet I
will go down there later on man why why
guy why guy would you live in a house oh
that's the only colored thing I've seen
besides blood
what is that candle all about I don't
need it
oh maybe I can go down to the basement
now because I actually have a candle
look at that look at how cool that is
the candle actually makes the blackness
go away the shadow creep you know like
creepin
what is that what is that is raining is
that rain tell me that's rain ah that's
me that's this guy my God why have you
forsaken me what this isn't normal guy
maybe you should be a little more
freaked out about it maybe I'm just
saying oh oh okay okay I mean this guy
is kind of walking through this Layton
well yeah oh darn it is there a burglar
in this house gosh darn it
but if there was a burglar in this house
he would've died a long time ago from
all the demons in your frickin place
it got darker
ready for that my key didn't fit it it
didn't fit and it didn't thing that made
me jump that made me jump it was a
jump-scare jumpy scares okay all right
okay I can't believe I'm taking rest
bite in the room full of skulls and
mannequins I feel better here than I did
out there
you guys gotta play this right now the
demo is totally free oh my god this game
is amazing I don't want to be here I
don't want to be here lipsti hurry along
hurry along please thank you no thanks
hey why did it get dark the swarming
shadows just cuz it's raining
uh-uh nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
doc crap I'm going to the basement
aren't I
hey there's a sealed letter do I want to
read that and know there's another
picture of slender man is Slenderman a
member of my Fiat
that I saw when the shadows were
creeping across his eyes I thought his
eyes became black but they kind of do
but it's just the way the shadows move
along in this place it's so cool oh not
the dolls yet let's go back into the
doll room for some strange reason let's
go back oh they're so weird - so weird
they're so weird why why are they so
weird mommy mommy can
hug Oh - okay all right
why is the window open there let's close
that something I don't know let's just
get out of here
ah and the toy soldiers keep marching on
see that still says mutter for EM DUID
I donno okay let's just go down into the
basement
cuz that's totally a good idea greatest
idea ever in a horror game go down
alright so it's gonna be eight look at
our horribly cracked walls cracking
voice oh good an axe what am I gonna
chop the heads off of all of it
why what happened what happened I have
no idea what the Davin
happened I have the ax now is that good
I have a feeling that if I was that
being in the darkness of the basement
made that happen
okay I have an axe to defend myself with
which I'm amazed that it's really weird
okay I'm assuming that only interactable
objects have color to them even though I
do not oh man when you play this game
play with headphones it got darker I
thought that the shadows are creeping in
ours are you ha ha ha No can I run can I
run could I please run
please what does that sound
what does that sound what is bangin who
we bangin we'll be banging out there
will be banging okay alright
it's like creeping Elena who's banging
oh the shadows are creeping in on me
shadows are gripping it all night hmm
don't give me don't kill me okay I'm
okay they're creeping in on me but
they're not getting that close wait a
minute this always going on way longer
than I remember I'm gonna brush it down
but down the dark get it down get it
done okay alright good idea honey
Oh what how oh no I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna you can't make me do that you
really can't make me do that
Oh what you gonna do I guess this is the
whole neverending nightmares part keep
waking up in a horrible new place that
was so cool ah so cool I didn't get to
play it impacts it wasn't a playable
thing all there was a playable thing but
I didn't go into it ah that was so cool
that was like the cool thing I want to
play more oh man I'm not just like that
that was amazing play for yourself guys
demo totally free playing oh my god who
is the coolest thing it was like the
coolest thing that was the coolest thing
it may not translated well on video but
that was the coolest thing oh okay I'm
done okay I'm sorry
who's this ooh cool it was like perfect
there wasn't even a monster and that's
the way it was supposed to be all I saw
were hints oh I had no idea what was
going on the entire time all that I was
left with me was the music and the sound
in the atmosphere and it was so
perfectly done and the style is amazing
turnout done Game of the Year ahh ok
anyway I'm done raving about it I said
that before that was really really
really cool you guys got to try that for
yourself so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you on the next video in the
next video bye bye
whoa
Oh
Oh No
yeah
everything's brown pastel
we're fly